WE THANK THEM FOR WHAT THEY ARE
DOING FOR US, BRIAN?
BRIAN: ABSOLUTELY.
THE PARENT OF THREE FRESHMAN AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF AMHERST SAYING
THEIR DAUGHTERS LOST OUT ON
TELEVISION AND HOUSING NEXT YEAR
ALL OVER THIS PICTURE POSTED
ONLINE SHOWING THE STUDENTS
MASKLESS AT OFF CAMPUS PARTY.
THEY ARE HOPING TO AVOID FILING
A CLASS ACTION LAWSUIT AGAINST
THE SCHOOL AFTER SUSPENDED THE
STUDENTS FOR THE SPRING SEMESTER
REFUSED TO REFUND THEIR $16,000
TUITION.
THEY COULDN’T EVEN REMOTE LEARN.
THOSE PARENTS JOIN US NOW.
KRISTIN, BETSY, R.J. AND TERESA.
KRISTIN, LETS LET’S START WITH Y
>> WHAT I THOUGHT OF THE
PICTURE.
BRIAN: YES.
>> I THOUGHT THE PICTURE WAS
CUTE.
IT GOT THEM THROWN OUT OF THE
SCHOOL.
BRIAN: JUST NOT HAVING A MASK.
>> THEY WENT TO GATHERING OFF
CAMPUS ON SATURDAY.
THEY TOOK A PICTURE.
AND ANOTHER STUDENT POSTED IT
SCREEN SHOT OF THAT PICTURE
INSTAGRAM AND SENT IT TO THE
ADMINISTRATION.
SO THAT PICTURE VIRTUALLY GOT
THEM KICKED OUT OF SCHOOL.
BRIAN: BETSY, WHEN THAT PICTURE
POPPED UP AND THE RAMIFICATIONS
BEGAN TO COME IN, WHAT ARE YOUR
THOUGHTS?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, THANK YOU
FOR HAVING US.
BRIAN: NO PROBLEM.
>> AND HELPING US TO SHARE OUR
STORY.
THIS IS OBVIOUSLY DEVASTATED
THREE FAMILIES.
BUT, FOR US, YOU KNOW, WE LIVE
IN MARYLAND, MY DAUGHTER AND I.
THIS PICTURE POPPED UP AND THE
UNIVERSITY WAS SWIFT AND FIERCE
IN THEIR ACTIONS.
THEY GAVE MY DAUGHTER REST THAN
NINE HOURS TO MOVE OFF CAMPUS.
ESSENTIALLY MAKING HER HOMELESS
500 MILES FROM HOME WITH NO
RECOURSE.
THEY DIDN’T HELP HER.
THEY DIDN’T ASK HER IF SHE HAD A
PLACE TO GO.
THEY DIDN’T ASK HER IF SHE HAD
THE ABILITY TO FEND FOR HERSELF.
THIS HAS JUST BEEN A TERRIBLE,
TERRIBLE INJUSTICE.
I JUST DON’T FEEL THE PUNISHMENT
FITS THE CRIME.
BRIAN: NO KIDDING.
OF COURSE IT DOESN’T.
R.J. AND THERESA FROM YOUR
PERSPECTIVE, I KNOW THERE ARE
RULES ON CAMPUS.
BUT MY GOODNESS WE ARE ALL
MAKING THIS UP AS WE GO ALONG.
SOME THINGS WE HAVE BEEN TOLD IN
THE PAST ARE TOTALLY WRONG.
NOW YOU TALK ABOUT MARCH, KIDS
ON CAMPUS IN COLLEGE.
SHOULDN’T BE THERE BE SOME PLAY
IN THESE RULES?
>> I DON’T THINK THEY WERE VERY
CAREER IN THEIR EXPECTATIONS OF
THE STUDENTS.
BEFORE THE WEEKEND WHEN THIS
EVENT HAPPENED.
THEY WARNED, THEY SAID, YOU
KNOW, MAKE SURE YOU DON’T GATHER
AND MAKE SURE YOU DON’T DO THIS.
THE MONDAY FOLLOWING THE
GATHERING, ALL OF A SUDDEN NOW
ANYBODY WHO -- ANYBODY WHO WAS
INVOLVED IN ANY EVENT IS GOING
TO BE SUSPENDED.
YOU KNOW, TO ME, IF YOU REALLY
DON’T WANT SOMETHING TO HAPPEN
MAYBE YOU LET THEM KNOW WHAT THE
EXPECTATION IS BEFORE, BEFORE,
YOU KNOW, SOMETHING COULD
HAPPEN.
I DON’T KNOW.
>> GOOD MORNING, BRIAN, THANKS
FOR HAVING US.
THERE WAS ABSOLUTELY NO
PRECEDENT SET FROM A SUSPENSION
PERSPECTIVE.
OUR TAKE IS IF THEY SAY THEY DID
SOMETHING WRONG, OKAY, THEY DID
SOMETHING WRONG, THE PUNISHMENT
IS ENDURED FOR THE LAST TWO
MONTHS HAS BEEN MORE THAN
ENOUGH.
AND THE SUSPENSION IS DRACONIAN.
IT’S COMPLETE OVERKILL.
SO, WE JUST WANT WHAT’S RIGHT
FOR THE KIDS.
THE UNIVERSITY SHOULD ALLOW THEM
TO LOG BACK INTO THEIR PORTALS
SO THEY CAN FINISH THE SPRING
SEMESTER.
BRIAN: OF COURSE.
>> GET THEIR CREDITS FOR THE
SPRING SEMESTER.
THESE KIDS HAVE PUT IN OVER 300
HOURS EACH OF SCHOOLING.
THEY ARE ALL GREAT STUDENTS,
HONOR STUDENTS.
THESE ARE THE TYPE OF STUDENTS
THAT U MASS SHOULD WANT AT THEIR
CAMPUS.
AND THEY NEED TO DO THE RIGHT
THING TO START MAKING THIS
RIGHT.
THE KIDS HAVE PAID THEIR
RESTITUTION, PAID THEIR DUES,
LET THEM BACK IN TO GET THEIR
CREDITS AND MOVE ON FROM THERE.
BRIAN: YOU DIDN’T GET IN A BAR
FIGHT.
YOU ARE NOT DRINKING AND
DRIVING.
YOU TOOK PICTURES ARM IN ARM IN
A MASK IN COLLEGE.
WHO HASN’T DONE THAT AT 18, 19,
NOBODY.
I JUST WANT TO READ YOU WHAT THE
UMASS AM HEERS TRIED TO EXPLAIN
THIS STATEMENT:  WILL KRISTIN, H
MUCH DOES THIS COST TO YOU NOT
HAVE YOUR KID BE ABLE TO MINUTE
FINISH THE SEMESTER?
>> IT’S BEEN HEART BREAKING
WATCHING MY WELL-ADJUSTED
DAUGHTER BE EMOTIONALLY
DISTRAUGHT IT’S BEEN
HEART-BREAKING.
FOR MY WHOLE FAMILY.
AT THIS POINT I DO NOT KNOW WHAT
TO DO.
I DON’T KNOW HOW TO HELP THESE
GIRLS ANYMORE.
I’M AT A LOSS.
ALL WE WANT IS FOR THEM TO TAKE
THEIR EXAMS AND FINISH THEIR
COLLEGE PATH AND THEY ARE
JUST -- THE SCHOOL HAS BEEN
ABSOLUTELY SHOWED NO COMPASSION
TO US THAT’S ALL I WANT IS
WHAT’S FAIR AND JUST WANT THE
GIRLS TO CONTINUE ON THEIR PATH
TO GREAT STUDENTS, GREAT KIDS.
BRIAN: OBVIOUSLY.
AND BETSY, HOW MUCH MONEY ARE
YOU OUT?
>> YOU KNOW, I’M A TEACHER.
I’M A SINGLE PARENT WITH TWO KID
IN COLLEGE.
I TEACH EDUCATION IN OUR LOCAL
COUNTY SCHOOL.
WE DON’T HAVE A FINANCIAL POT OF
MONEY.
MY DAUGHTER TOOK OUT LOANS ON
HER OWN TO PAY FOR SCHOOL.
THIS IS COSTING US WAY MORE THAN
$16,000.
MY DAUGHTER IS DEVASTATED.
SHE IS BROKEN AND CRUSHED.
AND SHE DOESN’T EVEN WANT TO
CONTINUE.
SHE DOESN’T WANT TO GO AMHERST.
BRIAN: DO YOU KNOW WHAT?
IT’S A GREAT SCHOOL AND HAS A
GREAT REPUTATION BUT THEY DON’T
DESERVE YOUR DAUGHTER AND YOUR
KIDS AND THEY HAD A HUGE PARTY
WHEN U MASS WON THE HOCKEY NCAA
TITLE.
EVERYONE WAS ALL OVER EACH
OTHER.
THAT WAS THE NEXT MONTH OVER IN
APRIL.
WHERE WAS THE OUTRAGE ON THAT?
THERE WAS NONE.
KRISTIN, BETSY, R.J. AND
THERESA, YOU’VE ALL GOTTEN THE
SHORT END OF THE STICK.
I FEEL BAD ABOUT THAT.
BUT THANKS FOR TELLING YOUR